I'm here with Briony creative director
Justin O'Shea and we're going to take a
look at his Dracula inspired I would say
very rock and roll debut collection
Metallica
they're in your first campaign that's
some rock and roll [ __ ] how did you
approach Metallica just gave Nicole
instead of a Metallica dude do you want
to be in a [ __ ] awesome campaign and
they said yeah Justin I'd love to all
right Justin so your first collection
for Briony I noticed a sort of like two
prong element to the collection what's
the deal there is a good guy there's a
bad guy I don't like meeting you you're
like a good diet and I'm like the bad
guy [ __ ] so demeaning I don't like
doing these anymore the bad guy is
shades of gray shades of unusual green
and then it's black it's sort of like a
ruby red and then it's ivory if you can
pull up an ivory suit then you are a bad
guy you've been making a lot of noise
for how different the direction you're
taking this brand is but a lot of it
seems rooted in things from the past
that people don't necessarily know about
any of these brand is the heritage brand
everything I want to do is authentic to
the brand right tell us about dawn yeah
the sunglasses did not ever exist before
they never even I heard you drew those
on a cocktail napkin I drew them on a
cocktail napkin on a plane emailed it
and I was like these are gonna be the
glasses right it was met with are you
drinking yeah and I was like maybe yes
what do you call this badass curry this
is actually called battleship gray so
there was a battleship gray there was a
mid gray and I was also in castle great
in the beginning after I decided on the
inspiration I took a helicopter and flew
over bran castle in Transylvania you'll
probably never be in Ellicott the world
but does again the color was the deepest
gray of ever seen and so a small medic
the castle great comes from the roof
Browns of various Brown this the things
Brown is like a color that's being
forgotten from suits the 70s they wore
brown suits that by 2016 the wild you
leave out the Browns you know it's like
it's just blues what's up with this
suede coat oh yeah what's up with this
we could happen being totally awesome
did you notice the sterling silver
hahaha I'll move covers the Continental
suit love the Continental pinstripes are
always gangster it shows you're
different to a normal guy yeah it's like
you actively have chosen something which
isn't boring right speaking of not
boring the silk very comfortable to you
in this print actually well girls will
touch me you know the beauty of wearing
velvet is everyone wants to touch you
yeah that's true and it just looks
expensive man it looks expensive
yeah you shouldn't touch it actually it
is expensive package take Becca here
easy as that Briony creative director
Justin O'Shea GQ star in chief will
Welch that's how it's done